[Music]  they said that they wanted to hit the  ground running as soon as they were  married and that's exactly what they did  the royal couple made their first post  wedding public appearance today  celebrating the 70th birthday of Harry's  dad Prince Charles the brand-new Duchess  of Sussex wore a pink dress by goat  fashion and a saucer shaped hat by  Philip Treacy the highlights making  sharing a laugh with Charles and Camilla  after a bee buzz to close to Harry  during his speech b11 does this perhaps  the reason they're doing this engagement  today is just to put the spotlight back  on them so that they can then slip off  quite quietly we've had the wedding  pictures we've had the first engagement  I would imagine at some point in the  next week to ten days things will go  very quiet on the Sussex front and that  will probably be because they crept off  very quietly to go and have what Harry  is determined to be a private honeymoon  [Applause]  you